Hey youtubers it’s charlie, I hope you all
had an awesome thanksgiving.
Currently it’s black friday and people are
stabbing each other with pens and stepping
over bodies to get cheap stuff.
So naturally I thought it totally appropriate
to do a top 5 things to look forward to in
Game of Thrones season 4 for Joffrey Baratheon.
There’s also been news recently that Jack
Gleeson is going to quit acting after he’s
done playing Joffrey.
So I’ll address that as well too.
And there’s an official season 4 teaser
coming soon.
Lots to look forward to, be sure to subscribe
to get all my videos.
If you’re finding me for the first time
or you’ve never seen any of my Game of Thrones
season 4 videos.
Because season 4 hasn’t happened yet there
may be some spoilers based on events that
have already happened in the books.
So if you don’t want spoilers then just
turn down the volume and turn on automatic
captions.
And this can just be a funny video with captions
that don’t make any sense.
Seriously automatic captions are awful.
The big thing to consider about Joffrey in
season 4 is that there’s really one big
thing he has in the books.
So what is the show going to do to expand
his part.
Which starts our list off with...
Number 5 - Extra scenes.
Because Joffrey isn’t a POV character in
book 3 but on the show he’s a main character
they had to change a lot of scenes so that
they were told from his perspective.
That’s how a lot of characters get scenes
that weren’t originally in the books.
This will happen again in season 4 because
Joffrey has some big surprises headed his
way.
Extra scenes also allow for the actors to
improvise things.
Like this (insert joffrey sansa wedding scene
- tyrion).
Number 4 - More malevolence.
Joffrey will continue to get even more evil.
Even though Joffrey isn’t a targaryen he
is on the same path as the mad kings.
He’s even the product of sisterwiving which
also happened with a lot of the targaryens.
So as the series has progressed he’s gotten
crazier and crazier.
There was that moment at the end of season
3 when it almost seemed like Tywin was going
to jump across the table and strangle him
to death, but the show was fairly true to
the book and it just ended in this amazing
tense moment.
Number 3 - The rains of castamere.
So if you remember, the song was turned into
the Lannister theme on the show.
Whenever a lannister character is on screen
it plays really softly in the background,
but during scenes like the red wedding it’s
literally played by characters.
That’s not going to happen during Joffrey’s
wedding to margeary, but I’m really hoping
that the song plays softly in the background
during the wedding feast.
Number 2 - The Purple Wedding.
Even if you haven’t read the books you may
have heard the term ‘The Purple Wedding’.
It’s the name fans have affectionatly given
to Joffrey’s wedding to Margeary.
It’s called the purple wedding because sansa
wears a hair hairnet covered in amethysts,
which are purple.
And she unintentionally plays a big role in
Joffrey’s wedding.
Number 1 - The purple wedding feast and the
aftermath.
So not only is the feast going to be one of
the most talked about moments on television
next year, from a production standpoint it’s
one of the most epic scenes the show has filmed.
The scene was shot over a five day period
and included more principal cast members than
almost any other scene they’ve ever done.
There were 23 regular cast members and over
218 extras on set.
Don’t be surprised if HBO promotes next
season using “Save The Date” invitations.
But let me know what you’re biggest questions
for joffrey in season 4 are and what you’re
most excited to see.
So to address the rumors that Jack Gleeson
is quitting acting after Game of Thrones you
have to watch a recent interview he did at
Glasgow College.
There was a student that asked him what his
plans for the future were and he responded
by saying he didn’t think that acting would
interest him as much as doing something else.
Gleeson actually does some cool theater work
with his friends when he’s not filming game
of thrones, they actually do a puppet show
which will hopefully get posted online in
the future.
But David Benioff and DB Weiss actually said
during a recent interview that they expect
he’ll go into higher education because he’s
one of those actors who’s really smart in
real life and very interested in university
life.
In related season 4 news, this time last year
was when we got our first voice over teaser
for the next season.
So I would expect to see our first season
4 teaser in the next couple of weeks.
Nothing has been announced, but as soon as
it posts I’ll do a new video for it.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
As always be sure to let me know which character
you want to talk about next and I’ll add
them to my list.
Here’s my schedule for the rest of the weekend.
Tonight is legend of korrra book 3, saturday
will be Doctor Who 50th easter eggs part 2
and Sherlock Series 3 and sunday will be the
mid season finale of walking dead.
RIght now click here to learn about my other
game of thrones season 4 videos and click
here for my doctor who easter eggs video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives.